hey guys any holiday holidays can you
believe it it's already December no I
don't it's so good
no I can't you know I don't even know
what does he done brush swear refused to
believe it no this year has been so
crazy right like 2015 like thankfully
it's almost over cuz it's been insane
but it's been an eventful year though
hasn't it
you got me moved to new home got engaged
JK's got it their new studio Castro
we're kind of filming they're kind of
not but yeah and it's pretty cool cuz
this year we're gonna be going to Miami
to visit my cousin we're doing two
destinations this year for for our
Christmas / New Year's travels this year
we're gonna go to Miami visit her family
first yeah then to Dallas to visit my
family so it's gonna be a double-header
two-parter we're about to get on a plane
we're about to go to our trip so we
really really really have to get our
last-minute Christmas shopping done so
earlier today we were shopping online on
walmart.com and we ended up realizing
that they have like same-day pick up so
we can go pick up our gifts same day at
lifesaver definite lifesaver so because
of that we want to show you guys what we
got today for our family and see what
you guys think
all right first item is a Roku TV 55
inch TCL Roku and would you like to tell
them why we got this one
it gets received in this one it's a
Christmas gift for ourselves
one we actually do have a Roku already
in our belters bedroom and
this room where we are standing right
now we haven't actually had time to buy
a TV set for this room yet yeah so we
were shopping online we've realized that
there was a really good deal for this TV
and we were like oh should we just get
it for ourselves a Christmas present for
us so we convinced ourselves to just get
this to eat
that's our number our present number one
number two let's go for the next one
light it up help me slide it out baby
moving it out all right
present number two it's another TV but
this is a Vizio 55-inch it's also a
smart TV so the risk and all same stuff
Netflix Hulu Vudu crackle Facebook so
the reason why we decided to get this TV
was because my grandma my sweet sweet
grandma she's been bugging me saying
that she's been wanting a TV recently so
like ooh for Christmas I should get her
a TV and I'm really excited for to see
like her eyes lit up
she's not ready for this I know it's
pretty crazy like but on a film I feel
really blessed even able to to give this
for my grandma cuz I know it's gonna
make her really really happy shut
thoughtful I'm not I'm never this tough
for me ever people are you really you're
gonna be thoughtful or what was the
thing you like for your back nothing
you've never bought your parents
anything they don't like it you should
suck em something cuz even though they
like it they still get you stuff good
you're getting given last year I like
you know for Christmas we were like they
told us like occasionally you know we
don't really do Christmas here that much
I guess what you like to or whatever do
they saw like how I asked you first
yeah I'm over that's the percentage you
haven't noticed the guys I remember last
year as parents were like nope yes but
still like so because I expected that I
was just like okay no kids but then they
still give me a gift every level
yeah you should still get your C I'll
get my grandma TV you gotta get your
your parents something Oh next gift next
one alright so yes number three and four
BAM Pokemon
this is Pokemon Sun and Pokemon moon
pokemons really really genius with this
and the fact that they always release
two games simultaneously and the first
generation of games that when we were
growing up was the pokémon red and blue
game so you remember that I never was
into Pokemon
yeah but these are on Nintendo 3ds games
who are they for
I have a cousin who is super into
Pokemon and poking my eye she came back
like it has a second life right now
hopefully you'll enjoy this on his 30s
alright and the next gift is this LG
tone Pro wireless earphones I'm actually
getting this for my cousin Jenny because
I saw that she owned a pair for herself
and cuz we talked on the phone often
because we're best cousins like that she
was telling me that her headset just bro
so I was like oh perfect Christmas idea
she like lives with her pair and so ever
since they broke she's been like pretty
bummed out every time I talked to her on
the phone it's like oh I can't do things
I have to hold my room dumb kidding but
yeah I know she's gonna love this so I
got this for her was next I got my
brother and his girlfriend back home
they're trying to get into fitness and I
thought hey why not I get them a Fitbit
charge too and a Fitbit flex too but
both sequels yeah you know what I
realized Christmas is also a really good
time to start the whole new year
resolution because
the gifts and then the resolution comes
in right after the guests come Ken yeah
these things you wear on your wrist and
they look like a watch but it's not a
watch way it does tell time but what it
really does though is it tracked your
movement how many steps to take or how
active you are and they'll gauge make
your heart beat your heart rate
everything like that until the gauge how
much calories you lose next up is this
really really really cool smart art too
deep I like this one intelligent robot
Bluetooth thing that is a toy I'm
actually getting this for love it he's
been like in this whole Star Wars phase
right now yeah I guess what you can do
is I remotely control it like a remote
like a robot a pet r2d2 hi next gift is
for my cousin Jenni's husband his name
is Joe we got him this swiss tech jacket
something that keeps them warm yeah I at
me but I mean they stick it it can get
chilly a Ivies live in Florida it does
get kind of yella don't not this gift
not not that I picked you all just not
everything we live in LA to actually
never use that culture here but we have
checked anyways I got into present for
Joe he works on the linemen which is
like the guy that put up like the
electrical poles and stuff and so he
works outdoors a lot so thinking yes
even though he lives in Florida right
now I mean big good chili - all right so
I know I said I don't find my parents
gifts that often conceptually is a
full-circle gift because they taught me
how to cook so I figured actually give
him something back in return that kind
of rides along the idea that you know I
like the cook they taught me to cook I'm
going to give them awesome pants
nice to the Pioneer Woman from our
frontier to yours oh that's nice okay
yeah way to it's a 10 piece set that's
way too much done box I think I messed
up Packaging arrived in already just put
extra Christmas bows on it I'll never
know I opened it except when they watch
this video all right so that's what we
got the Walmart I hope you guys enjoyed
our little haul video now we're just
going to wrap these babies up and we'll
be ready to go
[Music]
all right so the presents are all rats
and ready to go yay
so make sure to check out in the
description box below links to all the
things that we showed you guys and you
get to check them out for yourselves and
don't forget that you can always rely on
Walmart for your last-minute holiday
shopping they have up until Christmas
Eve I think that you can even pick up in
store if you order online so make sure
to check them out and thanks for
watching guys thank you Merry Christmas
[Music]